المشهد الميداني تركز بشكل اساسي في
العاصمه الخرطوم بدون بمدنها ثلاث تحليق
مكثف للطيران الحربي مع تواصل الاشتباكات
في محيط القصر الجمهوري وقالت قوات دعم
سريع انها تصدت لهجمات متكرره من الجيش
الى شمال قليلا في الخرطوم بحري هزت
انفجارات وسط المنطقه
واتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في سماء حي
الوابورات وقال الجيش ان من وصفهم
بالمتمردين هاجموا منطقه الخرطوم بحر
العسكريه ومنطقه العاصمه العسكريه مؤكدا
انه تمكن من صد الهجوم
وفي الخرطوم بحري كذلك قال الدعم سريع ان
الجيش شنهجمات على مقر لدعم سريع قرب سلاح
المظلات في المنطقه الغربيه من الخرطوم
بحري تحديدا منطقه حله حمد
في شان الميدالين اخر قال الجيش السوداني
قوات دعم سريع اجبرت مهندسين على تعطيل
محطات التحكم للكهرباء
عن مناطق واسعه بالبلاده بينما نفت قوات
الدعم سريع ذلك وقالت انها تعمل على
استعاده الخدمات مع الفرق الهندسيه